- Everybody has their own signature,
their own direction.
And when you ask any one here in this room
to write their name,
they're all gonna be very different.
And some people probably will probably
some calligraphy like,
and that R starts to now sprout legs,
such as thing, you know, dance.
And then when it becomes radical,
the R is right there and it just
has a kick to it.
And then Renaldi brings
it to another level
where it becomes so abstract
it's still an R, but
it becomes an animals,
just morphs into a whole thing.
And then when you add
another letter to that,
it just becomes this whole
abstract war machine.
It's pretty amazing.
You know Taki would write like this,
literally like this, crude, in 1970.
And if he probably
would have kept writing,
he probably would have
made that T like that
and then the K and then the I
and then it becomes more stylistic,
more calligraphy, and it becomes
more attractive, you know?
So that's what we're doing, but we were
actually not realizing creating this like
really kind of like new language. (laughs)